Cory these credits are they just as
important to the company as the
batteries themselves well let's first
give credit to the linguistic renee's ID
range right now is very personal it's a
nice euphemism isn't it so yeah so Elin
introduces I do in a tweet on Sunday
morning when all of us you know
financial quarters were waiting for news
to report on puts in his Twitter he puts
his Twitter account he says Tesla press
conference at 9am on thursday about to
end range anxiety via OTA saw software
update affects the entire model as fleet
so we'll find out tomorrow morning what
this means and what this might mean it
was a what might range anxiety mean
Tesla's are limited in how far they can
drive 200 miles for the the one version
of the car or 265 miles they say for
another version of the car but perhaps
even worse in places where the weather
is cold and sometimes that matters a lot
if you're going for a long drive say
going from Los Angeles to San Francisco
that's a range problem here so what's
interesting is it makes us want to look
at what these batteries are what
decisions Tesla's made around these
batteries and and what's interesting is
that the batteries are very important
the car they're very important to the
business and in many states across the
country they get credits or generate
credits for the manufacturers of the
cars because they're making zero mission
cars so really simply for every car they
make that doesn't pollute they can sell
a credit to another car maker that does
pollute and they're able to generate
these credits in many states across the
country and use those credits in
California and increasingly that's
bringing a lot of money for the company
the more cars they make the more credits
they make so in the last quarter that
got it to be as much as 66 million
dollars now you might say what's 66
million dollars this money losing
company centage of sales it was all over
the place but the 66 million that it
generated that was thirty-three percent
of gross profits last quarters it was
nearly forty percent of gross profits
the previous quarter so this is a
material issue for this company how long
can they generate these credits is that
one of the complaints about Tesla is
that the comfort is that the company
keeps talking about these exciting new
things it's doing but that these you
know Corps financial fundamentals
are really not that impressive and
continued to deteriorate is that what
we're seeing now you know Elon Musk it
makes a big announcement about this new
software update ending range anxiety
meanwhile the real story is this tax
credit issue well it's certainly the
promise of Tesla is always in the come
right if you look at the results you
look at the results in the rearview
mirror and sometimes they don't always
look so good sometimes it look weird if
you look in the future if they talk
about self-driving cars and hyper loops
and Giga factories and in you know
solving range anxiety always looks
exciting so that's why i love this is a
story right it gives us a chance
actually look at what's happening and
sometimes that can differ from the
reality and when I looked at these range
are these zero emission credits is it's
really peculiar you think about for
every car they make they get credits
about equal to the number of cars but
the the tax credits per car number one
at some quarters they were zero but
they're going way up even as Tesla says
they're selling more cars
internationally in the text of their sec
filing says we're going to have fewer
range credits or fewer a zero emission
credits and and because we're selling
overseas we're not going to generate
these credits so the numbers really
don't track with what they're saying in
terms of of what they're writing down in
their information with SEC filings it's
a very weird thing and as I point out is
I think it's really material to their
gross profits hmm so they really do need
to rely on the US market here for these
credits what is Elon must sing about all
this on Twitter uh well I'd love to tell
you I do as much to my surprise last
night when I went to check the
punctuation of the earlier tweet that I
showed you that Elon Musk has blocked me
on his Twitter slide so yeah it's it's
fairly unusual uh he somehow has decided
that I should be blocked so I can't
actually look I cover the company of
course and they clearly he released his
financial information or information of
importance like an important press
conference are having it on Thursday on
the Twitter account but I'll to get that
from other since it was scandal the
Twitter coming back story backstory he
blocked you from following him on
Twitter what happened I don't know I
discovered that I last night as I was
checking my back to the store I it's
unusual I don't know that it's
you know I could still read the
financial filings I can still model the
company i can still talk to current and
former executives a couple i can still
report on it but i can't read his
twitter you just have to log out of
Twitter and then you can still see them
so that you can always get around that
and you know there's always the fake
Elon Musk tweets which right which are
funnier in okay so almost as
entertaining great